1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 100, 200, 300 !
Ca fait donc 300 jours que je relève le défi de vous faire une vidéo chaque jour depuis le 1er janvier.
Pour parler directement ou indirectement de mentalisme.
Et aujourd'hui pour cette 300ème vidéo, il faut que je vous fasse un cadeau, que je parle d'un truc un peu gros !
Je vous avez toujours dis qu'en tant que mentalos,
oui "mentalos" je n'aime pas ce surnom [imite les abonnés]
vous n'etes pas obligé de tous vous sentir concernés quand je dis "mentalos".
Je disais donc, je vous avez toujours dis que j'avais une approche pédagogique un petit peu de cette chaîne.
C'est-à-dire que je vous donnez des choses étape par étape pour faire toujours de plus en plus gros au fur et à mesure de l'année.
Et si vous avez suivi les vidéos un petit peu dans l'ordre, vous vous rendez compte que c'est le cas.
Chaque vidéo s'appuie ni plus ni moins sur d'anciennes vidéos.
Jusque là, c'est très clair !
Et bien aujourd'hui je vous explique comment deviner précisément un prénom auquel pense une personne.
[rires] "Mais tu as déjà fais ça Fabien sur la chaîne !" [imite les abonnés]
Oui ! Et presque deux fois en plus.
Sauf qu'à chaque fois vous demandiez à la personne de choisir quelqu'un qui était dans la pièce, par exemple.
Et vous déduisez à quelle personne elle pensait.
Là on parle de penser à un prénom et de trouver ce prénom !
[musique du générique]
Autant vous dire que cette vidéo elle fait partie des vidéos en mode c'est du lourd mec, qui a eu sur cette chaîne.
Vous m'avez souvent demandé comment faire ça, et si je vous avez donné à l'époque la réponse telle que je vais vous la donner là, maintenant,
vous n'auriez pas pu, en tout cas je pense, apprécier la manière de faire et ça vous aurait surement décourager.
Alors que c'est tout à fait viable.
Li'dée est donc de demander à une personne de penser à un prénom.
Ca... on l'avez compris !
De l'écrire d'une part, de le dire à personne, que ce soit juste dans sa tête.
Et vous vous allez devoir extraire cette info.
Pour ça, il vous faut une pince à crabe.
Ou quelques astuces de mentalisme et un bon sens de la logique !
Vous choisissez, c'est un petit peu comme vous voulez.
La première étape elle consiste... Oui je m'assied je suis un petit peu faigué.
Elle consiste à déterminer quel est le rapport entre la personne à qui vous essayez de faire ça, et la personne à qui elle pense.
Vous allez lui demander de réfléchir, si c'est quelqu'un de sa famille, quelqu'un au travail, quelqu'un parmi ses amis.
Parce que, et ça je ne l'ai pas précisé, vous devez lui demander de penser à quelqu'un qu'elle connait, quelqu'un qui existe dans son entourage.
Quelqu'un à qui elle parle de temps en temps, ou très régulièrement.
Une fois que vous avez déterminé ça, je vous expliquerai comment après, vous devez déterminer plus précisément la personne.
Si c'est quelqu'un de sa famille, est-ce que c'est son frère, sa sœur, son oncle, sa tante, son père, sa mère, son grand-père, sa grand--mère...
Trouvez ça !
Si c'est dans ses amis est-ce que c'est son meilleur ami, si c'est au travail est-ce que c'est son patron, un collègue ?
C'est très important parce que la troisième étape du processus va être de trouver l'age approximativement de la personne.
Est-ce qu'elle est dans les 40 ans, dans les 50 ans, dans les 30 ans, dans les 20 ans, dans les 10 ans, dans les 1 an ?
C'est possible ! Tout est possible !
Ca vous donnera déjà une bonne image, parce qu'en faisant tout ça vous aurez:
A peu près l'age de la personne, son rapport avec la personne avec qui vous parlez, et le sexe de la personne.
Haha !
On avance Sherlock !
Ensuite vous allez chercher à déterminer les premières lettres du prénom de la personne.
Alors pour ça, je vous rappelle, je vais vous la mettre par ici...
qu'on a fait une vidéo pour trouver à quelle lettre pense une personne.
Vous allez simplement utiliser ce processus pour trouver 1, 2 ou 3 lettres.
Et en utilisant une technique de cuberlandisme, par exemple, comme je vous l'ai expliqué aussi sur la vidéo sur le cuberlandisme.
Vous allez pouvoir déterminer le nombre de syllabes qui composent le prénom.
Avec toutes ces informations au va passer au stock reading.
Si vous savez que la personne est une femme, que c'est la mère de la personne à qui vous parlez,
vous connaissez l'age de la personne qui est en face de vous, si la la personne pense à sa mère et que la personne qui est en face de vous a... on va dire 35 ans,
Donc ça veut dire que sa mère a entre 25 à 35 ans de plus qu'elle en moyenne.
Que vous déterminez que la première lettre du prénom c'est un M.
Que la deuxième est un A.
Il y a de fortes probabilités que le prénom de la mère soit Martine.
Parce qu'à cette génération là, à cet age là, les prénoms féminins commençant par "Ma" indiquent que statistiquement c'était Martine le prénom le plus donné.
Mais, en plus de ça vous pouvez affiner avec le nombre de syllabes ou des lettres supplémentaires.
Evidemment le travail préalable à faire c'est de se renseigner, de potasser un peu en stock reading, le travail sur les prénoms générationnels masculins et féminins des différentes générations.
Forcément, parce que sinon je n'aurai pas dit le mot "générationnel" !
Evidemment il va falloir appliquer ça à une culture ou à plusieurs cultures si vous voulez le faire.
Par exemple tu me fais ça avec un prénom indien moi je suis foutu, c'est terminé tu vois.
Le plus simple pour commencer c'est quand même de faire dans sa propre culture, dans sa propre langue.
Ok... tout ça c'est plutôt pas mal, c'est un peu fou mais comment on fait du coup pour trouver la catégorie famille, amis, etc ?
Et bien, c'est là qu'intervient la lecture des signaux non verbaux dont je vous ai parlé plusieurs fois.
Que ce soit dans la détection de mensonge, dans l'astuce pour trouver à qui pensait une personne dans la pièce, dans l'astuce pour trouver à quel film pensait une personne...
Tous ces éléments là sont des outils pour vous, pour comprendre dans un plan séquencé à quoi pense une personne.
Vous allez comprendre à quel point toutes ces vidéos là étaient des outils ayant pour but, entre autres, d'atteindre la 300ème vidéo pour vous faire cette révélation.
Je sais qu'il y aura deux types de réactions à cette vidéo.
Ceux qui se diront: "Ah bon ? Mais c'est tout ? C'est que ça ?" et ceux qui vont comprendre en fait le petit bonbon que c'est en fait.
C'est surement un des trucs les plus personnels que je révèle sur ma chaîne.
Alors ce n'est pas une méthode miracle, vous avez vu, il faut aussi un peu de culot, un peu de connaissance générale sur le stock reading pour les prénoms, pour les différentes générations, homme et femme.
Il faut avoir plusieurs cordes à son arc pour être capable de déterminer un age approximatif, une relation avec quelqu'un...
Et ça quelque soit l'information que je cherche, de toute manière je séquence les choses par des choses très binaires.
Est-ce que ça fait partie de tes amis ou  ta famille ou du travail.
Une fois que j'ai la réponse, tac, je vais creuser un peu plus loin.
Mais au final même si vous êtes juste à coté du prénom, ce serait quand même très perturbant parce que ce sera quasiment le prénom.
J'espère que vous apprécierez toute cette démarche la qui a dans cette vidéo.
Pour moi c'est beaucoup là que je vous donne aujourd'hui, personnellement.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
N'oubliez pas, si elle vous a plu de vous abonner également à la chaine.
Puisqu'il reste encore 66 vidéos avant la fin de l'année, avant le 31 décembre.
Il y aura encore des vidéos l'année prochaine, rassurez vous !
Et le Mental Vlog vous dit à demain, 17H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]